let's say i have this bizarre looking
function it's just some arbitrary
function and we'll call that f of x
so this function right here is f of x
we're going to do in this video is it's
not an experiment but we're going to
play around a little bit and we're going
to try to approximate this function
using a polynomial with some
coefficients and this this polynomial
we're going to do we're going to keep
adding terms to the polynomial so that
we can better and better approximate
this function and that's actually called
a power series and we'll we'll do more
about that later but we're going to
specifically try in this case to
approximate the function around x is
equal to zero so around this point
so the easiest way to approximate it is
to say well
the simplest polynomial is just a
constant right let's see if this is my
polynomial let me call my polynomial p
of x
the simplest polynomial is just a
constant and it would just be a
horizontal line someplace so if i just
wanted this one term polynomial what
would be my best approximation for this
function at least at this point well i
could just set p of x is equal to
f of zero
and in that case p of x would just look
like a horizontal line
going through f of zero it would just
look like that
i'm going to erase that now just so i
don't dirty up this picture too much but
that's
you could say a very rough approximation
of f of x right
so let me undo that and undo
so that's a start
well what would be a one way to
approximate it even more well what if
not only does p of x equal f of zero at
x is equal to zero
oh whoops
right so not only does
so that horizontal line we did in that
horizontal line we got p of zero
is equal to f of zero so we knew that at
x equals zero
at least that horizontal line is the
same value of f of x that's a very rough
approximation but what if we set it up
what if we set it up so that the
derivative
the derivative of p of 0 is equal to the
of the function at 0.
all of a sudden this could be a little
bit more interesting so how can we set
it up like that well what if we set p of
x
what if we set p of x i'm doing very
general and we're going to do specific
examples and actually the first example
we're going to do is probably the
coolest one
so what if p of x is equal to well the
constant term is f of 0
f of 0
and then it's plus
the derivative of this function so the
slope of this function at that point
f prime
of 0
times x
let's say i'm defining so this is a
polynomial i just added a first degree
term here at a constant and now i'm
adding a first degree term and let me
confirm that this will have the same
derivative so let's see first of all
let's confirm that p of zero is equal to
f of zero well p of zero
p of zero is equal to
f of zero
plus f prime of zero
times zero
well this last term just goes to
is nothing right times 0. so
that checks out at what f of at x is
equal to 0 the two functions are equal
to each other
now let me confirm that their derivative
their first derivatives are the same so
what's the first derivative
of p
p prime
of x is equal to well the derivative of
a constant term is zero right plus and
what's the derivative of an x term of a
first degree term well it's just f prime
of 0
f prime of 0.
so this checks out my my new polynomial
that i've defined right here
is equal to the function f at x is equal
to zero and its derivative is equal to
the function f at at x is equal to zero
so what would it look like
well it would intercept it would
intersect at x is equal to zero the two
functions would overlap and also they
would have the same slope at that point
so whatever f x is doing that function
is going to be doing so it's going to
look something like
i'm going to try my best to
it's going to look something like
that
and so that is a better approximation if
we had to use a line that's as good as
any especially around zero
of what f of x is so we you know the f
of x might have been some really crazy
uh weirdo function but we were able to
approximate it reasonably well with this
very simple linear equation
well that's all good but let's let's
make it let's approximate it with a
quadratic equation with adding another x
squared term
and we're going to do that way we're
going to say well we said
that when at x is equal to 0 the
functions equal each other that's what
we did here
then we said that the derivatives equal
each other and so we added this term
and now i'm going to say what happens
when they're second derivatives equal
each other so what has to happen for
their second derivatives to equal each
other
well let's let's try out
this and i think you'll start to see the
intuition here let me define my new p of
x so let me add another term
p of x
i'm going to the first terms are going
to be the same we're going to be f of 0
remember this is just a constant term
plus
f prime
of 0 the first derivative at 0 the slope
at 0 times x
plus
f
prime prime the second derivative
of the function
at 0
times x squared
over 2.
now you're probably saying why are you
adding this why are you multiplying it
by one half here and you'll see and
maybe you'll even realize that when you
take a second derivative what happens
right you multiply the expression by the
exponent so you can have a 2 come down
it's going to cancel out with the one
half and that's why i put the one half
there so that that when i take the
derivative that two and the one half
cancel out and i'm just left with the
second derivative
of the original function so let me
confirm that
so p of zero
is equal to f of zero
plus well when x is equal to zero that's
zero this term is zero and when x is
equal to zero that term is zero right
so that checks out
what's the first derivative of
p
the first derivative of p
is going to be
the first one up here this this was
the first derivative of p at zero
right
so what's the first derivative of p
well the constant term becomes zero
plus oh actually no this this was
actually of x sorry i i shouldn't go
back on my work i know it best when i'm
doing it the first time around anyway
the first derivative of p of x this is
my current p of x
this constant term derivative zero this
x term the derivative is f prime
of zero
and then what's the derivative of this
term well we take the exponent multiply
it by the expression so we have 2 times
1 half that cancels out so we're just
left with f prime prime of 0
x
right you take the exponent multiplied
by the whole thing and then decrement
the exponent by 1.
so what is what is p prime of 0 what is
the derivative at 0
well it equals this is nothing it equals
f prime of 0
plus and well this term is going to be
0.
so that checks out
and so what's the third derivative
what's the third derivative let me let
me clean up some of this stuff on the
top
since this is our current f of x anyway
i can clean up all of this stuff
let me clean up all of this
let me clean up all of that all right
so what is the third derivative of this
p that i defined
here
this is our current p
well the third derivative is going to be
so p
prime prime prime of x we could have
also written p 3 of x
is equal to
the derivative of this oh no sorry we're
not on the third we're only on the
second derivative
p and i'll write prime prime i was going
to write a 2 there p prime prime of x
that equals
that equals what that's the derivative
of this
so there was a 0 here that goes nothing
this constant this is now a constant
term that becomes nothing and then we
take the derivative of this term
as well we just
it's a constant times x remember this
might look like a function or some
variable it's just a constant because we
evaluated this
this curly this curvy function
its second derivative zero so we just
got a number here so this derivative is
just this number so it equals
f prime prime
of zero
and so our current p of x
has the same
value when x is equal to zero as f of x
it has the same first derivative at x is
equal to zero as f of x it has the same
second derivative and i don't i'm this
is getting beyond of my uh my
visualization ability especially for an
arbitrary function like this but i could
guess that maybe it looks something like
this i don't know maybe it looks
maybe our new function will curve and
it'll approximate it a little bit better
and then maybe it'll come down like that
i don't know i'm just guessing but
around x is equal to zero it's going to
be a better approximation of f of x
well we could just keep doing this and
actually we will keep doing this and and
you know just saying well the
the zeroth derivative or at the value is
the same the first derivative is the
same at zero the second derivative is
the same zero we'll say the third
derivative the fourth driven will keep
doing that and i only have 20 seconds
left in this video so we will continue
that in the next video